-Here at "Late Night"
every night,
I deliver a monologue made up of
jokes written by
a diverse team of writers.
As a result, a lot of jokes
come across my desk
that due to my being
a straight white male
would be difficult,
if we're being honest,
It would be difficult for me to
deliver.
But we don't think that should
stop you from enjoying them.
So we'd like to share them with
you now in a segment called
"Jokes Seth Can't Tell."
♪♪
-Hey, everybody.
These are two of our writers
Amber and Jenny.
-I'm black.
-And I'm gay.
-And we're both women.
-And I'm not.
So here's how it works --
I'll read the setups to these
jokes and Amber and Jenny
will read the punchlines,
here we go.
According to the New York Post,
dressing like a lesbian
is the newest fashion trend.
-"That's great news,"
said the makers of Crocs.
[ Laughter ]
-According to a recent survey
the fastest growing group
of gun owners is black women.
-This news was first reported
in a threat from grandma.
[ Laughter ]
-Now, Amber,
was your grandma strict?
-My grandma was so strict
she had her name legally changed
to "Ma'am."
[ Laughter ]
-One of the Cohen brothers
is reportedly planning to direct
a film
about a lesbian road trip.
-It's called, "Look How Easily I
Just Changed This Tire."
-Ooh.
[ Laughter ]
-Seth, you know what's fun
about lesbian road trips?
-What's that?
-They all start out
in different places but they all
end up in the same place --
a Natalie Merchant concert.
-Oh.
The Labrador Retriever was
recently voted the number one
dog breed in the U.S.
-And white people celebrated
by kissing one on the mouth.
[ Laughter ]
-Now, Amber, is kissing dogs the
grossest thing white people do?
-No, Seth, the grossest thing
white people do
is gerrymandering.
-Oh.
[ Laughter ]
-And out lesbian judge was
recently appointed to
the 2nd U.S. Circuit
Court of Appeals.
-A lesbian judge is like a
straight judge except when she
says, "Please approach the
bench" it's to point out
all the places where it needs to
be sanded."
[ Laughter ]
-Still my favorite.
-Thank you.
-FIFA, the governing body of
soccer recently hired it's first
black woman referee.
-Instead of red cards
and yellow cards, she'll just
give players this look.
[ Laughter ]
-And now was that a yellow card
or a red card?
-A yellow card.
-Okay.
Can you show us all a red card?
[ Laughter ]
-A dog was recently dropped off
at a shelter after its owner
became convinced it was gay.
-Their first clue was when
the dog looked at them and said,
"You're wearing that?"
-And now, Jenny,
what's the first clue
that a dog is a lesbian?
-It has three cats.
-Ah.
[ Laughter ]
-Scientists have reported that
some black holes have,
what is referred to as hair.
-Whish is rude because
I told you that in confidence.
[ Laughter ]
-Did that joke, did that go the
way you thought it would go?
-Yeah, but I feel ashamed that I
said it.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-A new article on insider.com
outlines the steps lesbians
need to take to prepare for
retirement.
-Step one, stock up on
batteries.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh! [ Laughs ]
Oh, batteries.
[ Laughter ]
According to a recent report
the 2020 census over counted
white people --
-In their defense,
it's easy to lose track because
you all look the same.
-Oh, come on.
[ Laughter ]
No we don't.
-Seth, counter point.
[ Laughter ]
-Hey, Seth,
why don't you tell one?
-No, I couldn't!
-Come on, just one!
-I just don't feel like
it'll end well.
-Oh, come on.
-Do it!
-Okay, okay. I trust you guys.
I trust you guys.
Judge Ketanji Brown Jackson
will become the first
black female to sit
on the Supreme Court.
I can't believe Biden managed to
find a black woman
with an opinion.
[ Light laughter ]
-Seth! How dare you?!
-You said it would be okay!
-You should be ashamed of
yourself.
-Yellow card?
-Yellow card.
-Red card?
-Red card!
[ Laughter ]
Black women and lesbians
are liars!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Check out "The Amber Ruffin
Show" run by these two.
A new episode's up on Peacock
this Friday.